Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Machen wir jetzt eine Sendung oder was?
Die Sendung ist aufgenommen worden, wurde verbreitet und verkündet. Und sie war gut gewesen.
Musik Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 472 vom 11. Oktober 2023.
Früh am Morgen und alles ist schon vorbei.
Die Sendung hat sich sozusagen selbst aufgenommen und verkündet.
In Übereinstimmung mit der Prophezeiung.
So sieht's aus. Und ja, wir reden gar nicht lange drumherum,
sondern wir bringen einfach sofort knallhart das erste Feedback,
nämlich von Luca, der schreibt, die Zeitform bzw.
Das Stilmittel, was Linus benutzt, um den Kongress anzukündigen,
hatte auf Englisch den schönen Namen prophetic perfect tense.
Oder prophetisches Perfekten, da heißt es, das prophetische Perfekte ist eine literarische Technik,
die in der Bibel verwendet wird, um zukünftige Ereignisse zu beschreiben,
deren Eintreten so sicher ist, dass sie in der Vergangenheitsform erwähnt werden,
als ob sie bereits geschehen werden.
Ja also die goldenen zwanziger waren super oder sind super gewesen das ist glaube
ich das korrekte weil es ja perfekt nicht zu verwechseln heißt es dann nicht
mit dem futuren was heißt es nicht was war die goldenen zwanziger?
Waren die dann nicht perfekt?
Sind perfekt gewesen. Ja, also es ist ein bisschen...
Es gab, wie heißt das so schön, Störungen im Betriebsablauf.
Mit den mit den zwanziger jahren ja also es ist wirklich also ruppig es läuft
es läuft ruppig an aber es ist wie bei der bahn irgendwann kommt der ICE.
Da will ich mich auch nicht drauf verlassen.
Bisschen Hoffnung muss man ja schon noch haben.
Naja, auf jeden Fall bedanken wir uns bei Luca für diesen interessanten Einblick,
war mir auch noch nicht so ganz so klar, dass das sozusagen das prophetische Perfekt,
das ist gut, sind, das müssen wir noch mal ein bisschen üben,
mal gucken, vielleicht können wir das ja heute noch zum Einsatz bringen.
So dann der nächste Kommentar ist von Marc und er bezieht sich auf Design by Committee.
Übrigens nochmal dieses hässliche Auto was ich bei Wikipedia sieht wenn man
Design by Committee dieser Pontiac Aztec oder Aztec oder was auch immer nennt.
Da geht man gar nicht mehr aus dem Kopf, so hässlich wie der ist.
Und ich glaube, dass Walter White bei Breaking Bad den am Anfang fährt.
Du glaubst das.
Ja weil wie lange ist Breaking Bad her? Aber.
Lange ich hab's nicht gesehen von daher kann ich damit mich nicht zu äußern.
Also Breaking Bad ist eine sehr gute Serie.
Ja hab ich schon mehrfach gehört, dass das.
Also das hat dir gefallen. Also ganz eigentlich in der.
Naja also ich meine mit amerikanischen autos tue ich mich eh schwer also wenn
die also die was die halt nicht können sind so kompakt autos deswegen bauen
die ja jetzt auch diese SUVs. Diese schiffe.
Breaking Bad warum fährt Walter White eines der hässlichsten autos der welt den Pontiac Aztec.
Also er fährt den wirklich.
Jetzt zu Beginn ja.
Und warum?
Also da gibt's irgendwelche Trivia, Vince Gilligan hat das persönlich ausgesucht,
auch die Farbe fahren grün, ich denke einfach auch um zu zeigen,
dass der im Leben halt einfach nix, nix hat er sich zu freuen,
der war ja sehr unzufrieden mit seinem Leben, der.
Lass uns auf den Kommentar von Marc zurückkommen zu diesem Thema,
das Auto spielt jetzt erstmal glaube ich nicht so eine Rolle.
Also zu Design bei Comity. Man kann es auf die einfache Formel bringen.
Kunst und Demokratie schließen einander aus. Das gilt für Musik,
Bildende Kunst, Design, aber auch technisches Design und Engineering gleichermaßen.
Ist auch nicht weiter verwunderlich, denn Demokratie verhandelt Interessen auf
der Basis der Gleichwertigkeit aller Menschen. Das ist eine komplett andere Aufgabenstellung.
Demokratische Prozesse führen naturgemäß zu Kompromissen aka Mittelwertbildung.
Für Kunst ist das Gift. Oder willst du Musik hören, die so mittel ist?
Ja guter Punkt also ich meine das was hier so ein bisschen mit drin steckt ist
halt auch so diese Proliferation demokratischer Ansprüche an Stellen wo es manchmal einfach nix bringt.
Ja das ist eh so ein Problem.
Ja die Piratenpartei hat sich ja ihren organisatorischen Prozess gleich vom
Start weg komplett zerschossen als sie hier in Berlin eingezogen sind,
weil irgendwie alles muss jetzt irgendwie basisdemokratisch.
In der Partei ist es natürlich schon so, dass Demokratie grundsätzlich als Anspruch
vielleicht besser angebracht ist als jetzt zum Beispiel.
In der Partei ja sofort, aber halt nicht in der Organisation der Landtagsfraktion.
Also das ist halt irgendwie das Gift gewesen von Anfang an.
Egal, da müssen wir nicht einsteigen, aber ich weiß genau was gemeint ist und
ich würde dem einfach zustimmen.
Das ist etwas, also kreative Prozesse, aber auch, sagen wir mal,
so Entscheidungsdinger, Firmen, Projekte und so weiter.
Es ist halt einfach manchmal sinnvoll, die Entscheidung für bestimmte Bereiche
einfach einzeln oder zumindest sehr kleinen Gruppen zu überlassen.
Und wenn alle mitbestimmen wollen, dann kommt am Ende halt einfach nur brei, Pontiac, Artstek.
Ja, Design by Committee. Also es ist tatsächlich, manchmal auch mit Design zu
tun und da hab ich das auch das ein oder andere Mal bezeugen können oder auch mal verhindern können.
Blau.
Blau, genau. Jonas schreibt uns zum Thema Blau. Linus, ich erkläre dir jetzt noch den Witz.
Das ist immer schlimm. Als ich das gelesen habe, habe ich gedacht, nein, tu es nicht.
Man erklärt nicht einen Witz, man macht ihn. Anstatt seiner werde ich diesen Witz erklären.
Ich hab ja auch wirklich nicht verstanden.
Der Witz des Profs war...
Also es geht ja um den...
Sollen wir den Witz nochmal erzählen? Okay, ja bitte.
Wie ging der Nummer? Wenn man alle fragt, ist am Ende blau oder so? Das war der Witz, ne?
Ja, das kommt ja jetzt.
Geht weiterhin um Design, ja.
Jetzt geht's konkret um blau. Also Linus, ich erkläre dir jetzt noch den Witz.
Der Witz des Profs war, dass man sich am Ende immer auf blau einigt,
weil es eine Kompromissfarbe ist, mit der am Ende alle irgendwie leben können.
Da lacht die Designerin, weil es ein fauler Kompromiss ist.
Mein Zusatz war, dass ich die CDU zwar auf blau einigen konnte,
aber nicht darauf welches.
Also nehmen sie einfach zwei. Das ist designmäßig nochmal unterirdischer,
als sich einfach für eins zu entscheiden und zu sagen, schaut her,
das ist jetzt unsere Farbe.
Vielleicht hatten sie sogar drei zur Auswahl und konnten sich zumindest darauf
einigen, dass da doch zu viel ist. Trotzdem danke fürs Vorlesen.
Okay, die verstehen es sogar schon.
Christian fügte dann noch an, egal ob das jetzt besonders witzig war,
denke ich, dass es vermutlich stimmt. Blau ist das farbigste Grau.
Man denke einfach an die Farbe von Autos oder Anzügen.
Liegt eventuell an den Farben des Himmels, der immer irgendwie im Hintergrund
ist, ohne selbst für etwas zu stehen.
Boah, ey, sag das den Leuten mit der Bibel, dass der Himmel für nichts steht.
Oder Blue Sky. Wenn Grau, Schwarz und Weiß zu langweilig wirken, landet man bei Blau.
Andere Farben wirken zu grell, aggressiv oder man assoziiert damit sofort etwas.
Könnte allerdings auch sein, dass das Verlangen nach mehr Polizei den Hang zum
Blau bestärkt. Mittlerweile ist die Polizei ja universal blau und nicht mehr grün wie früher.
Interessante Feststellung.
Anzugfarbe.
Passt.
Guck mal, jetzt kenne ich drei Designer-Witze.
Ich kenne jetzt drei Designer-Witze. Also den Blauwitz kenne ich.
Dann hat der Designer nix drauf, macht da einen Verlauf und Körnig mit M zu
schreiben. Das ist der dritte Designer-Witz, den ich kenne.
Also Keming.
Das sind die drei Designer Witze und mit denen komme ich eigentlich gut durchs Leben.
Bist einfach bestens Größe. Ja da ist was dran. Blau.
Okay. Das farbigste Grau.
So, Sternbuck schreibt uns zu Twix, ah, ich persönlich bevorzuge Xyta.
Okay, also gut ich nicht.
B Tim, aber sowas von, ich finde aber auch dein was Vinicius twigs,
ja find ich auch nicht gut, aber egal.
Find ich auch nicht gut, aber geht gut von der Zunge und alle wissen was gemeint ist.
Okay, aber da gibt es auch noch eine inhaltliche Ergänzung.
So Tim, vielleicht ist es dir nur rausgerutscht, aber Bluesky gibt es nicht
nur als App, sondern auch ganz ordinär per Webseite und dafür gibt es auch bereits
jede Menge Fremdanwendungen, wie zum Beispiel deck.blue, einen passablen Tweetdeck-Klon.
Richtig. Genau. Ja, das ist richtig, das hatte ich nicht erwähnt, ne?
Ansonsten halt Applikationen wie Gefolgte von Twitter erkennen und übernehmen.
Achso ich dachte Follower, das wäre praktisch.
Ja das ist halt das was da jetzt so stattfindet.
Wer ist die meist geblockte Person und warum ist es Anna Schneider etc. Wer ist Anna Schneider?
Ist so ein Twitter Troll, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab die Diskussion darüber gesehen, aber ich hab die nie wahrgenommen.
Also meine Bloglisten haben schon immer ganz gut funktioniert.
Beziehungsweise meine Follow-Listen haben wahrscheinlich schon immer gut funktioniert. Nicht wahr?
Sie ist als Chefreporterin bei der Deutschen Tageszeitung Die Welt tätig.
Ja gut, da hab ich die Antwort auch so gefunden.
Da muss man gar nicht, da brauchen wir gar keine App für, ja genau,
ja also bei Blue Sky tut sich gerade ja viel, da kommen ja gerade auch die anderen.
Ich hab die gegoogelt, ich hab Anna Schneider gegoogelt, dann hab ich auf Google
ihren Twitter Link gefunden, dann hab ich da drauf geklickt und jetzt steht da blocked.
Sie ist deswegen die meist geblockte Person, weil sogar ich,
der sie nicht kennt, sie geblockt habe.
Ah, und Anna Schneider ist blockt, okay. Warum auch nicht.
Ja, okay.
Kann man alles, siehst du, man geht alles mit Blues geil.
Nächster Kommentar geht um die tollen NFT-Marken der Post.
Sind die jetzt weg? Die wurden doch jetzt bestimmt alle aufgekauft von unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern.
Paradex. Hallo, hier nur ein krasser Nachtrag zum wichtigsten Thema der Sendung.
Kryptomarken. Die deutsche Post ist auch hier late to the party,
denn Nordbrief hat bereits in Kooperation mit dem Wacken Open Air eine limitierte
Anzahl an Kryptomarken herausgebracht.
50.000 Stück. Diese ist hier doch so unbeliebt gewesen, dass sie weiterhin im
Shop gekauft werden kann.
Limitierte Wacken, wer ist denn Nord, also kann ich mit Nordbrief dann,
also liefern die Briefe auch außerhalb von Wacken aus, oder?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab das erste Mal davon gehört, dass es die gibt.
Naja, also okay, aber pass auf, das ist auch die Briefmarke von Wacken 2023,
da sind ja noch nicht mal 50.000 Leute hingekommen, die sind doch alle im Schlamm stecken geblieben.
Ein original Wacken Produkt.
Erste NFT-Krypto-Briefmarke in Deutschland. Und sie ist aber auf 50.000 Stück weltweit limitiert.
Hochwertiges Sammlerwallet im Wacken-Stil.
Also das sind halt einfach Marketing-Abteilungen im Warenzustand.
Das kann man nicht anders sagen.
Wacken-Stamp with NFT. Ja, kannst du den Wacken-Leuten nicht andrehen.
Steffen hat noch eine Anmerkung zu dem Thema und schreibt, moin Leute zum Thema Krypto-Briefmarke.
Grob kann man in Sammler von gestempelten, also gelaufenen Marken und ungestempelten,
postfrischen Marken unterscheiden.
Daneben gibt es noch reine Motivsammler. Die Marke hat einen Zweck und diesen
sollte sie aus meiner Sicht auch erfüllen. Nämlich einen Brief slash Paket befördern.
Dann ist sie natürlich gestempelt.
Paketmarkensammler ist natürlich
auch... achso, ne, die gibt es ja auch in schönen Paketmarken, okay.
Jetzt lass mich erst mal vorlesen, dann kann ich gleich eine dumme Witze dazu machen.
Dann ist sie natürlich gestempelt und wird am besten noch als Ganzsache,
das ist ein kompletter Brief oder Karte, gesammelt.
Was da ein NFT soll, keine Ahnung. Hat nicht mal eine Gummierung zum Aufkleben.
Daher glaube ich nicht, dass dieser Krypto-Schwachsinn-Briefwerken-Sammler anspricht.
Eher Seiteneinsteiger, die nach Wertanlagen suchen. So wie früher die Leute
die jede neue Marke kauften und sich hinlegten in der Hoffnung der Werten möge steigen.
Danke für euren super Podcast und so weiter. Okay machen wir.
Ja das sind mal Einblicke aus der Philatelie bringt alles nix.
Mal gucken. Wird sie wahrscheinlich auch drauf sitzen bleiben die Post.
Soll ich mal den nächsten machen?
Wenn du möchtest.
Der ist zu DDR und Nazis. Da habe ich ja gestern in der letzten Sendung mich
in das für mich unsichere Terrain der Geschichte der Deutschen Demokratischen
Republik begeben und habe gesagt,
die DDR wird sicherlich ähnliche Probleme mit dem Mangel an nicht ehemaligen
Nazieliten gehabt haben.
Und dazu kommentiert der Jade-Affenjäger Linus Darstellung, nach der sich die
frühe DDR und BRD gleichermaßen aus dem Verwaltungsapparat des NS-Regimes bedient
hätten, ist historisch nicht korrekt.
In der SBZ der sowjetbesetzten Zone und der frühen DDR wurde die Entnazifizierung
mit stalinistischer Gründlichkeit und oft auch der entsprechenden Willkür vorangetrieben.
In den Waldheimer Prozessen wurden 1950 ca.
3000 NS-Belastete im Schnellverfahren abgeurteilt.
Beim Aufbau von Verwaltung, Justiz und Sicherheitsapparat wurde großes Augenmerk
auf Linientreue gegenüber dem sozialistischen Staat gelegt.
Berufserfahrung, die man nur durch jahrelange Praxis im NS-Staat hätte erwerben
können, war im Vergleich dazu zweitrangig.
Die Posten im Staatsdienst wurden stattdessen in der Regel mit jungen Menschen,
NS-verfolgten oder emigrierten KPD-Kadern besetzt.
Jedenfalls denjenigen, die noch übrig waren. Eine düstere Randnotiz ist hier,
dass deutlich mehr Mitglieder der alten KPD der Weimarer Republik durch Stalins
Säuberungen umgekommen sind, als durch das NS-Regime.
Beispielhaft für diese Werdegänge seien hier Karl Eduard von Schnitzler,
Hilde Benjamin und erich mielke genannt.
Kennst du noch karl eduard von schnitzler?
Ich glaube nicht.
Der schwarze kanal.
Ach der, ja ja ja doch der ist von ein paar jahren erst gestorben.
Der gab es noch naja doch 2001 ok ist doch aber in den 20ern ging es ja ein
bisschen länger. Ja der hat ja ja ok alles klar verstehe.
Diese deutlich erfolgreichere in den Anfangsjahren wurde später gleich,
samt Gründungsmythos und Selbstverständnis der DDR, als besserer antifaschistischerer
der beiden deutschen Staaten.
Man ließ dementsprechend auch keine Gelegenheit aus, wiederum oft zu Recht auf
die NS-Vergangenheit der westdeutschen Führung hinzuweisen.
Gleichzeitig war die DDR selbst in weniger empfindlichen Bereichen des öffentlichen
Lebens häufig deutlich weniger wählerisch, wenn es um NS-Vergangenheit ging.
Auch eine zivilgesellschaftliche Aufarbeitung der NS-Vergangenheit wie später
im Westen gab es in der DDR natürlich nie.
Stattdessen wurde den eigenen Bürgern gebetsmühlenartig versichert,
dass sie sozusagen qua Geburt Antifaschistinnen und Antifaschisten wären.
Spannendes Thema, an dem die Unterschiedlichkeit der beiden deutschen Staaten
wunderbar greifbar wird, wie ich finde. Ja, vielen, vielen Dank für diese Aufklärung.
Spannend.
Ja, das hätte ich mich eigentlich auch mal zu äußern können,
das war mir jetzt nicht unbekannt, aber in dem Detail hätte ich es jetzt so
auch nicht darlegen können,
speziell auch, dass jetzt da so die KPD-Kader einerseits genutzt und andererseits
auch von den Stalinisten gesäubert wurden, das war mir auch nicht klar.
Karl-Edward von Schnitzler, der war ja damals, der war ja Pop im Westen.
Hast du das mal gesehen, schwarzer Kanal, sagt dir das was?
Ja auf YouTube oder so. Das war so die Propagandasendung im DDR Fernsehen,
wo da immer so die Westnachrichten durchgekaut wurden, also der saß da wirklich
mit seiner dicken Brille und hat dann halt irgendwie also wirklich gnadenlos
auf dem Westen rumgehackt und das war wirklich so das absolute.
Propaganda Outlet, aber es war halt für uns so lustig, dass wir halt einfach
Schwarzer Kanal immer geguckt haben. Es hatte auch diesen geilen Intro-Sound,
wo dann so ein Bundesadler auf irgendeiner komischen Sendeantenne rumhopst irgendwie.
Ja ja, der Schwarze Kanal. Ganz groß.
Karl Eduard und Erich Mielke auch noch und Hilde Benjamin die auch noch genannt
wurde ist so die Richterin die so Schauprozesse durchgeführt hat.
Hat ja super funktioniert.
Ja mit der Entnazifizierung, vielleicht könnten wir das einfach nochmal jetzt
so ein Programm anleiern.
Du meinst wir sind beim ersten Thema?
Scheiße, ich mein wenn das damals erstmal ganz gut gelaufen ist.
Ja mal gucken, wo wäre es denn angemessen?
Ja diesmal müsste man sich halt glaube ich ein bisschen mehr um die Zivilgesellschaft
kümmern, als um die empfindlichen Bereiche des öffentlichen Lebens. Aber ja, anderes Thema.
Und Entwahlen ist ein Thema. Scheiße.
Ja genau, wir sind doch schon mittendrin. Oder?
Ja, also ich habe jetzt relativ wenig dazu zu sagen, zu den Wahlergebnissen in Bremen und Bayern.
Ich glaube, die Aufzuarbeitung, das müssen andere machen oder können auch andere
einfach sehr viel besser.
Ich mache mir in letzter Zeit viel Gedanken über,
und das habe ich ja hier auch im Podcast schon öfter ausgeführt, über Versprechen,
die Gesellschaftssysteme Menschen machen und wie erreichbar die sind.
Also wie das erzählte, dass das politisch erzählte, dieser major consensus narrative,
oder auch das, die Versprechen, die Menschen für ihr Leben gemacht werden, für Leistung.
Also jedes Gesellschaftssystem sagt ja eigentlich so, pass auf,
so und so läuft hier der Hase.
Und wenn du nach folgenden Regeln spielst, dann kommst du hier voran.
Das machen auch Organisationen so, auch Unternehmen.
Die sagen ja, pass auf, Ziel des Unternehmens ist folgendes zu erreichen oder
folgendes zu produzieren, wir spielen nach diesen und jenen Regeln,
das sind unsere KPIs und wenn du da irgendwie schön mitmachst,
dann machst du hier mehr Geld.
Und dann gibt's natürlich immer in jedem solcher Systeme Leute,
die das nicht erreichen. Das liegt vielleicht ein bisschen daran,
dass die sich nicht ausreichend Mühe geben oder, dass die unbeliebt sind bei
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen oder so, ne.
Und dann hält das oder erfüllt sich für die das Versprechen nicht.
Und jetzt mal ganz wertfrei gehalten, ist auch ganz normal, dass sich für Leute
das Versprechen nicht verhält,
Weil es ist ja nun mal auch so eine Pyramide nach oben, also es muss unten viele
geben, damit es nach oben irgendwie aussortiert werden kann,
aber dann kannst du natürlich überlegen wie steil ist diese Pyramide und so weiter.
Naja, jedenfalls, wenn irgendwann das, was dir versprochen wird,
einfach überhaupt nicht mehr erreichbar ist,
und sich das System als falsches Versprechen herausstellt,
Bei einem Job dann kündigst du oder machst Quiet Quitting,
wenn die Organisation groß genug ist, dann setzt du dich einfach da acht Stunden
auf den Stuhl und nimmst das Geld mit,
aber man löst sich dann von dem System und man ist frustriert,
weil das System ein Versprechen macht, das nicht erreichbar ist oder das nicht glaubhaft ist.
Und mein Eindruck ist, dass das das ist, was eben gerade in großen Teilen unserer
Gesellschaft passiert.
Und das fürchterliche daran ist, dass es mir nicht einfällt, wie man das...
Zeitnah in den Griff kriegen kann, dass Menschen nicht mehr den Eindruck haben,
dass dieses System ihnen nichts mehr bietet.
Also es ist ja das Gleiche, was du in den USA auch hast,
dass da in den, sag ich mal,
ab von der sogenannten Prosperity,
der wirtschaftlichen Wachstumsperspektiven in Großstädten, in den Flyover-Countries,
Da sitzen ja die ganzen Abgehängten, für die es auch schwer ist,
eine Verwendung zu finden.
Worauf willst du jetzt hinaus?
Dass mir der Grund zu sein scheint, dass Menschen AfD wählen und kein Interesse an den,
sagen wir mal, bevorstehenden Problemen der Gesellschaft haben,
unter den jetzigen schon ausreichend unzufrieden sind.
Also ich habe mir die Wahlergebnisse ehrlich gesagt demografisch aufgesplitzt
nicht so genau angeschaut, aber ich habe gehört, dass halt gerade bei jungen
Leuten der AfD-Anteil deutlich gestiegen ist.
Ja und genau deswegen habe ich auch gerade hier meine Theorie noch mal so bisschen ausgerollt,
weil insbesondere junge Leute,
sagen wir mal eine,
also junge Leute, sagen wir mal irgendwie zwischen 20 oder zwischen 18 und 30 oder so,
ja, ja gerade eine Erfahrung, die die Erfahrungen machen,
dass ihnen irgendwie in der Schule alles mögliche erzählt wurde und dann auf
einmal so vieles sicher geglaubtes wegbricht,
ne, wenn du diese ganzen Gen Z Diskussionen hast mit, ne,
in die Finanzkrise geboren, dann ist die vorbei, dann kommt die Pandemie,
dann kommt direkt irgendwie Krieg und die alles bedrohende Klimakrise,
das heißt, da wird es natürlich auch potenziell schwierig an etwas zu glauben,
was eine Organisationsform darstellt und dir angeblich eine Zukunft bieten möchte.
Ja gut, ich wüsste nicht, woher
jetzt die Logik ist, dann automatisch sein Kreuz bei der AfD zu machen.
Das ist schön, dass du jetzt sagst, dass meine Theorie das auch nicht erklärt,
aber dann hab eine bessere, um zu sagen, wie kriegt man die jetzt dazu,
dass sie das das nächste Mal nicht mehr da machen.
Also wie man das ändern kann, ist ja nochmal eine andere Frage.
Erstmal muss man wissen, was ist der Grund. Und ich glaube, da gibt es natürlich
keine einfache Antwort.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall in den Raum stellen, dass das auch unter Umständen
alles was mit mit einem geänderten Medienverhalten.
Also so tiktok und so ist definitiv ein Medium was bei jüngeren eine andere
Bedeutung hat als in unserer Generation das kann man mal klar festhalten.
Was für unsere Generation alter nur weil du in meiner Generation bettelst auf
Anschluss sind wir nur lange nicht eine.
Battles im Sinne mit E oder mit A?
Also unsere Generationen. Ja? Also auch du verbringst nicht viel Zeit auf TikTok.
Halt dich jetzt mal so fest.
Und zwar gilt das sowohl für dich als auch deine Generation,
weil ich weiß, du bist natürlich genauso wie ich auch nicht normtypisch in deiner Generation.
Aber egal, selbst ob du die normalos oder die outlaws nimmst,
TikTok war da einfach kein Thema, wir unterhalten uns hier den ganzen Tag über Twix.
So und die anderen so, was?
Weil einfach die audiovisuellen Medien da stark übernommen haben.
Und YouTube only das war halt auch schon früher mal und diese Häppchen medial
Perzeption spielt schon ne Rolle. Und da haben wir natürlich wieder das gute
alte Thema des Algorithmus.
Und ich meine ich mag das ja auch selber so, Kindern so, wenn man die mal so
befragt so und wo sie ihre Nachrichten herholen, da freu ich mich ja schon wenn
dann gesagt wird so ja hier war auf Tagesschau auf TikTok.
Das ist dann halt auch wirklich auch mal Nachrichten.
Aber die Kinder die Tagesschau auf TikTok gucken die dürfen ja gar nicht wählen.
Jaja, jetzt schon. Das ist ja jetzt nicht seit diesem Jahr so,
das läuft ja alles schon eine Weile.
Ich will aber glauben, also nichts gegen TikTok, aber kann das sein,
dass das eher Instagram ist, was die Leute konsumieren, die jetzt gerade die
Nazis oder die jetzt wählen dürfen?
Ich will es auch gar nicht jetzt auf TikTok festmachen und sagen,
das Problem ist TikTok, sondern ich sag nur, der Medienkonsum ist ein anderer geworden.
So und die Leute tummeln sich in algorithmisch geprägten Medienumfeldern.
So wie wir aus der guten alten Darker-Gilde, wir haben immer so,
ja, wir kuratieren uns das selbst und hier handgepflückte Informationsquellen
aus dem Internet und das läuft hier alles in meinen geilen RSS-Reader oder in
meinen Twitter-Timeline irgendwie rein.
Wir haben uns das Internet noch richtig schön selber kuratiert.
Naja, aber das ist halt auch gar nicht so sehr ein Generationsding,
sondern das war eigentlich schon immer ein szenetypisches Verhalten.
Und andere Leute nehmen es halt wie es kommt. Und da kommt es halt bei dem einen
aus Facebook und war halt schon irgendwie extrem Werbealgorithmus getrieben,
wir hatten die Diskussion hier schon mit Cambridge Analytica,
Trump-Wahl und so weiter und warum sollten wir jetzt die Auswirkungen dessen
nicht auch langsam in Deutschland sehen?
Und dessen muss man sich jetzt mal bewusst werden.
Ich sage jetzt auch nicht, das ist der Grund und das ist das einzige und das
müssen wir abstellen und TikTok verbieten und dann wählen alle wieder linksgrün versifft.
Wird so auch nicht passieren, aber wir haben eine andere Gesamtlage,
wie sich junge Leute, aber auch ältere Leute informieren und wie sie mit Nachrichten bespielt werden.
Und es ist ja jetzt auch keine besondere Neuigkeit festzustellen,
dass die AfD in diesen ganzen Netzen halt einfach deutlich mehr Reichweite hat
als alle anderen Parteien.
Und wir wissen ja auch, dass es nicht nur Parteiwerbung ist,
die da abläuft, sondern es sind halt gezielt Gesetze, Fehlinformationen und
so weiter. Kurz vor den Wahlen ging.
Es ja auch wieder mal richtig ab und,
dann waren auf einmal,
wieder die Geflüchteten das Thema und auf einmal war das wieder das Problem.
All right.
Für uns ist eigentlich nochmal entscheidend, oder für uns, warum wir überhaupt
auf diese Wahl blicken, ist ja die Hessen-Wahl.
Da hat Nancy Faeser sich ja als Spitzenkandidatin Und ich hatte ihr wirklich
viel Glück gewünscht in Hessen, da haben wir wirklich mal mit ihr mitgefiebert.
Die SPD ist hinter der AfD, glaube ich, in den Wahlergebnissen in Hessen,
ich hatte alle Ergebnisse der Landtagswahl.
Ja, also die AfD 18 Prozent, die SPD 15,1, die Grünen 14,8.
Also drittstärkste Kraft mit 15 Prozent.
Verloren hat sie 4,7 Prozent. Ja, die Grünen haben 5 Prozent verloren,
die AfD hat 5 gewonnen, aber wie dem auch sei.
Es gibt natürlich jetzt die Debatte, oder es zeichnete sich die Debatte ab,
Muss Nancy Faeser jetzt zurücktreten oder nicht?
Nachdem sie als Spitzenkandidatin versagt hat.
Und da gibt es zwei Positionen, die ich da mal rausgesucht habe.
Einmal eine Autorin des Spiegel, die...
Moment, wo ist der Name? Ah, Sophie Gabe, die im Prinzip sagt,
also auf die Frage, wann ein Politiker oder eine Politikerin zurücktreten sollte,
gibt es eine eindeutige Antwort bei Korruption, Väternwirtschaft oder groben inhaltlichen Fehlern.
Nancy Faeser kann man nichts davon vorwerfen.
Sie hat eine strategisch unkluge Entscheidung getroffen, gleichzeitig Ministerin
und Spitzenkandidatin in einem Bundesland zu sein.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht etwas, für das man zurücktritt. Es war unklug,
diese beiden inkompatiblen Rollen in sich zu vereinen.
Damit kommt, dann beurteilt sie noch die Politik von Nancy Faeser als irgendwie
halbwegs erfolgreich oder so.
Den Teil weigere ich mich jetzt zu zitieren, weil das eine inhaltliche Bewertung ist.
Und dann gibt es nämlich den Markus Reuter bei Netzpolitik, der nicht jemals
zitieren möchte, der sagt, Innenministerin Nancy Faeser ist nicht zu halten
und dann natürlich auch sagt sie, sie wollte eine Chat-Kontrolle festhalten.
Sie liegt im Bereich der Vorratsdatenspeicherung seit bald einem Jahr ein fertiger
Entwurf des Justizministeriums für Quick Freeze ohne anlasslose Massenspeicherung in ihrem Haus vor,
aber sie reagiert einfach nicht drauf.
Sie wollte das Grundgesetz ändern, um sogenannte aktives Cyberabwehr zu ermöglichen, also Hackbacks.
Da will ich übrigens sagen, dass ich inzwischen eher ein Freund davon bin,
dass man aktives Cyberabwehr sagt, weil das, wie gesagt, es geht nicht um das
Back, sondern es geht um das Heck bei diesen ganzen Proposals und aktive Cyberabwehr
kommt dem noch ein bisschen näher.
Da steht zwar auch wieder Abwehr drin, aber es ist wenigstens der aktive Teil mit dabei.
Naja, Schönbohmen Affäre und naja, das Haus aufgeräumt hat sie auch nicht,
weil sie da ja immer noch die ganzen Unioner hat.
Aber das sind natürlich alles keine Rücktrittsgründe.
Kannst du bitte CDU-la sagen? Ich glaube Union hat die Karte.
Weißt du nicht, aber ok. Okay, ist in Ordnung.
Die ganzen eisernen CDUler hat sie da noch im Haus.
I see what you did there.
Die eisernen Hardliner von der CDU. Und Markus Reuter kommt zu dem Schluss.
Nach dem Wahldebakel in Hessen kommt sie nun auch noch geschwächt nach Berlin zurück.
Das kann nichts mehr werden. Feser ist nicht mehr zu halten,
wenn die Ampel nicht noch mehr Schaden auf sich ziehen will.
Tja, beide Argumentationen finde ich so halbwegs vertretbar.
Also ich glaube, wir sind schon längst aus dem Kulturraum raus,
wo man für solche Detailverfehlungen, die manche so sehen, aber andere noch
nicht, von einem politischen Prozess, der offiziell noch nicht abgeschlossen
ist, dass das deswegen irgendwie ein Rücktritt erfolgen kann.
Ich glaube das wird so nicht stattfinden und ich finde es auch irgendwo ein
bisschen, naja, da wünscht man sich halt gerne mal was herbei,
was man jetzt gerne hätte.
Gar keine Frage, hat sie an politischem Gewicht verloren. Das ist natürlich
klar. Wenn du als Wahlverliererin vor allem so, wie es gelaufen ist,
wieder zurückkommst, dann schärft das jetzt nicht unbedingt so deine politische Base.
Gerade wenn es ohnehin gerade windig ist im Ministerposten, aber ich meine es
ist halt im Innenministerium fast immer so.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie zurückgetreten wird und glaube auch nicht,
dass sie selber zurücktreten wird deswegen.
Aber es hat ja definitiv nicht geholfen.
Ich will, dass die Leute für richtige Verfehlungen zurücktreten,
weil das ist ja schon komplett außer Mode gekommen.
Ja stimmt, das ist aus Hamburg hergekommen, nun ja.
Also du würdest auch davon ausgehen, dass sie bleibt?
Ja davon gehe ich jetzt erstmal aus. Wenn es nicht so ist, dann nehme ich das
zur Kenntnis, aber ich habe da ehrlich gesagt keine Erwartungen.
Sag mal, es gibt ja auf jeden Fall ein Thema, wo ich meine Meinung schnell ändern
würde, ob die gute Frau zurücktritt oder nicht.
Okay.
Das ist ja die Testkontrolle.
Ja, wuhuu.
Wir haben ja gesagt, zuletzt sah es ja nach einem Ende im Rat aus,
weil sie einfach dann nicht auf eine gemeinsame Position kam.
Und jetzt hat die spanische Ratspräsidentschaft einen neuen Anlauf unternommen,
einen Text vorgelegt, über den die ständigen Vertreterinnen der EU-Mitgliedstaaten
abstimmen sollen, und zwar am Freitag, den 13.10.
Und wenn die ständigen Vertreter sagen, okay, wir wollen darüber abstimmen,
dass dieser Vorschlag in der darauffolgenden Woche durch die Mitgliedstaaten
im Rat abgestimmt werden soll.
Also die Abstimmung ist jetzt darüber, ob darüber abgestimmt wird.
Da kannst du ja nicht einfach abstimmen, du musst ja vorher darüber abstimmen.
Und wir wissen, die spanische Ratspräsidentschaft wollte Verschlüsselung gleich ganz kriminalisieren.
Die waren ja so hart, dass sie gesagt haben, wieso wollen wir überhaupt Verschlüsselung
erlauben? Das ist ja wohl eindeutig irgendwie ein bisschen eine Nummer zu weit,
ja? Da können wir ja gar keine, also Verschlüsselung, das wollen wir eigentlich überhaupt nicht, ne?
Und jetzt gibt es also ein Leak auf der Webseite Euraktiv.
Und da übersetze ich jetzt mal, der Ratsvorsitz,
also spanische Ratsvorsitz, steckt vor den Anwendungsbereich der Aufdeckungsanordnungen,
also dass etwas an die Polizei gemeldet ist, vorerst auf bekannte CSAM,
also bekannte Missbrauchsdarstellungen zu beschränken.
Und jetzt vorerst.
Die einstägigen Bestimmungen über Aufdeckungsanordnungen für neue Materialien und die,
die die Anwerbung von Kindern betreffen, also das Grooming,
sollen erst in der Zukunft gelten, wenn feststeht, dass die Aufdeckungstechnologien
ausreichend zuverlässig und genau sind.
Aber dann automatisch oder was?
Im Prinzip sagen Sie…,
Erst wenn, also wenn die Technologie da ist, dann wollen wir die auch verwenden,
aber wir erkennen schon an, dass es die gerade nicht gibt.
Gehen aber davon aus, dass es die geben wird.
Ja und wenn nicht, dann hat es ja auch nicht reingeschadet, dass wir es schon mal reinschreiben.
Und dann sagen sie, ja, und wenn aber jetzt die Technologien dann da sind,
dann braucht man nämlich nicht nochmal den ganzen legislativen Prozess zu machen,
sondern dann kann der Rat das einfach schnell entscheiden.
Aber weil es die Technologien ja nicht gibt, schreiben wir es jetzt nur so rein,
dass wir sie erst verwenden, wenn es sie gibt.
Achso, das heißt, Sie wollen, dass der Rat das dann eigenständig beschließt
ohne das Parlament und ohne die Kommission.
Genau, weil das sind dann nur noch so Umsetzungsanordnungen,
weil steht ja im Gesetz, dass sie es dürfen.
Also die Argumentation ist im Prinzip, ja komm.
Der Rat kann das ja nicht machen, also die Kommission ist gemeint, oder?
Doch, Sie sagen sehr spezifisch, also der Rat sagt,
dass der Rat auch für die weitere Ausweitung des Gesetzes zuständig sei,
weil angesichts der erheblichen Auswirkungen einer solchen Ausweitung des Anwendungsbereichs
von Abdeckungsanordnungen,
sagen Sie, wird quasi der Rat in der Lage sein, diese Aufdeckungsanordnung durchzusetzen,
ohne das EU-Parlament erneut zu involvieren. Das ist genau der Punkt.
Der erste Punkt ist schon skurril. Nämlich zu sagen, macht euch keine Sorgen,
das könnt ihr jetzt so abstimmen, weil wir sind uns ja darüber einig,
es gibt die Technologien noch nicht.
Deswegen schreiben wir mal ins Gesetz rein, dass man die verwenden darf,
wenn das Problem gelöst ist.
Im Prinzip ist das wie, also es erinnert an zwei Dinge, ich sag mal ein Beispiel ist der.
Ist der, wie hieß der noch, der meistverhasste Mann im deutschen Internet,
im europäischen Internet, Axel Voss, der nämlich ja auch gesagt hat,
ja, Technologien, diese Upload-Filter darf man nur verwenden,
wenn sie alle unsere Anforderungen erfüllen.
Er hat ja gesagt, unser Gesetz schreibt ja keine Upload-Filter vor.
Das spezifiziert ja nur, dass man all das braucht.
Aber da steht ja nirgendwo Uploadfilter, da steht ja nur Maßnahmen,
die den Upload verhindern.
Das ist das eine, an was es mich erinnert, dass er nämlich gesagt hat,
wenn, da war ja auch das Argument, naja, wenn das ja nicht geht,
dann können wir es ja auch in das Gesetz schreiben, weil dann geht es ja trotzdem nicht.
Und mit dieser Argumentation, jetzt kommt das zweite Beispiel,
an das mich das erinnert, und das ist die Online Safety Bill im Vereinigten Königreich.
Online Safety Bill haben wir hier am Rande ab und zu besprochen,
ist im Prinzip genau das gleiche. Das ist die Chat-Kontrolle-Gesetzgebung für UK.
Und da haben sie nämlich auch gesagt, ey Leute, die Technologien gibt's nicht,
keine Sorge, machen wir dann nicht.
Nur, wenn Experten bestätigt haben, dass die Technologien so und so sind.
Also, wenn ihr euch alle sicher seid, dass die Experten dem ja widersprechen,
dann können wir jetzt das Gesetz verabschieden, in dem das drinsteht,
wenn Experten das bescheinigen.
Und dann haben sie das Online Safety Bill beschlossen und eine Woche später
haben sie gesagt, hey, Leute, ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen,
die Technologien gibt es jetzt, das ist ja irre. Wirklich?
Du lachst? Einfach so.
Und dann haben sie gesagt, aber wir brauchen natürlich noch ein paar Experten,
die das bestätigen, dass man die auch so einsetzen kann, dass sie also kein
Brechen der Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung darstellen,
weil das ist ja der Kernpunkt, dass man sagt so hier, ist das eine Gefahr für
die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung oder nicht?
Und wir haben schon eine Idee, wen wir als Experten einladen.
Dann haben sie sich natürlich ein paar ausgesucht,
dann sind natürlich auch NGOs gekommen und dann haben sie gesagt ja okay,
also irgendwie euer Urteil darüber, das teilen wir so nicht,
da kann man ja geteilter Meinung sein.
Die haben den Druck aus der Debatte genommen,
um den Leuten vorzugaukeln, dass sie jetzt für eine Woche einfach anerkennen,
dass es die Technologie nicht gibt und in dem Moment, wo die Tinte trocken war,
haben sie gesagt, ja guck mal, das hätte der jetzt nicht gedacht,
aber die Technologie gibt es ja doch.
Also genau den Trick versuchen jetzt die Spanier, oder versucht jetzt die spanische Ratspräsidentschaft.
Also das ist, so und wie sie jetzt auch auf den Trichter kommen,
dass sie dann die Aufdeckungsanordnung erweitern können, ohne nochmal das EU-Parlament
zu involvieren, da denke ich, das geht darüber, dass sie eben sagen,
wenn die Anforderungen erfüllt sind an die Technologie, dann darf sie auch eingesetzt werden.
Das soll ja im Gesetz drinstehen und dann erfordert eben auch die Anwendung
des Gesetzes nicht, dass sie, oder die Anwendung der Technologie,
nicht, dass das Gesetz geändert wird. Ja?
Also, hast du jetzt verstanden, warum der Rat macht?
Nee, ist klar. Ich hab das nur so verstanden, dass der Rat dann irgendwas entscheidet.
Das kann ich mir jetzt so nicht vorstellen, dass der Rat dann ein beschlossenes
Gesetz sozusagen mehr Schärfe, Nachteile dazu führt.
Jedenfalls müssen sie nicht nochmal das EU-Parlament involvieren.
Weil sie sozusagen im Gesetz schon eine Automatik drin haben,
wenn es das gibt, dann machen wir das halt so.
Genau. So jetzt werden zwei Dinge passieren,
die Permanent Representatives, die werden jetzt entscheiden,
ob darüber nächste Woche abgestimmt wird.
Also die werden jetzt am Freitag entscheiden, ob darüber abgestimmt wird.
Es wäre natürlich schön, wenn die sagen.
Nein, also da findet quasi die Abstimmung statt über die Agenda des Ratsmeetings
vom 19. oder 20. Oktober. Du hast gemeint eine Woche später.
Da stimmen sie ab über die Agenda und den Text des Councils und dann, wenn 19.
Oder 20. im Rat das auf der Agenda steht, dann wird da, also der Vote auf der
Agenda steht, dann wird da auch irgendwie im Zweifelsfall darüber abgestimmt.
Und dann würde am 26. schon im Parlament über die Chat-Kontrolle-Verordnung abgestimmt werden.
Also es ist wirklich ein absoluter Krimi, weil jetzt da jeder irgendwie noch
versucht, die Nummer irgendwie zu retten.
Und das natürlich mit den, jetzt kommen natürlich die ganzen Tricks zum Tragen,
inklusive hier eben einer eines sehr,
sehr schlechten Hütchenspielertricks eben für eine Technologie zu stimmen,
mit irgendeinem If dran und dann eben sich zu überlegen,
wie man, oder sich einen einfachen Pfad bereitzulegen, wie man dieses If relativ
einfach wegifft oder erfüllt, das macht wenig Spaß, ja.
Also wenn man sich jetzt mal diese ganzen schmutzigen Politikspielchen da anschaut.
Letzte Woche, war letzte Woche, wo wir über die Antwort von Ilva Johansson zum
Strongly Worded Letter gesprochen haben und wie das jetzt sich so weiter verhält,
das ist schon alles sehr, ja, geschmacksintensiv.
Starkes Aroma.
War das letzte Sendung oder war das vorletzte Sendung? Ich verliere langsam den Überblick.
Das ist auch das geilste, du verlierst am Ende, also in diesem ganzen Hin und
Her, irgendwann verlierst du den Faden, aber ist auch egal.
Hauptsache wir wissen einfach noch woher der Geruch kommt, das ist schon vorletzte Sendung.
470 war das genau.
Ja, schlecht riechen tut auch.
Ich darf das schon noch so nennen oder?
Du das musst du mit.
Mit mir selber ausmachen.
Nee, mit Sternburg.
Sternburg sagt Xitter.
Xitter wird sie nicht durchsetzen.
Nein, Xitter sagt kein Mensch.
Aber ich hab das schon mal gesagt, warum sagen die Leute nicht einfach weiter Twitter?
Weil, also das tun sie ja teilweise auch, aber das muss ja dann immer wieder
kommentiert werden mit,
ja, aber jetzt, früher hieß es ja mal so, und weil es ja jetzt nicht mehr so
heißt und man muss ja dann immer das Richtige berichten, Man kann's ja auch
nicht sagen, weil man weiß doch, wie Journalismus funktioniert.
Nur weil wir da nicht dran gebunden sind, weil wir so Internet-Hallodries sind,
die einfach irgendwas ins Mikrofon reinreden, Heißt das ja nicht,
dass alle anderen das dann einfach so machen können?
Ist ja auch vollkommen egal ich sag twix alle wissen was gemeint ist und twix
ist jetzt auf jeden fall ein problem also war es jetzt schon die ganze zeit
und wird jetzt sozusagen auch immer schlimmer also es wird wirklich immer schlimmer.
Nun ja und was ist jetzt passiert seit der letzten sendung ihr werdet es natürlich
alle mitbekommen haben es gab diese furchtbaren terroristischen übergriffe angriffe.
Überfälle auf israelische Bürger und Militäreinheiten.
Das ist sozusagen, ja so, ich fand mal den Vergleich so 9-11 und Pearl Harbor
in einem für irgendwie Israel.
Also wirklich ein Moment, der in der Geschichte dieses Landes ganz tiefe Spuren
hinterlassen wird und ja,
dabei sind über tausend Leute ermordet worden und natürlich eskaliert das ganze
jetzt ein Krieg, wo halt auf allen Seiten noch sehr viel mehr sterben werden.
Und was ist auf Twix los? Auf Twix wird ohne Ende jetzt antisemitischer Verschwörungswahnsinn geteilt.
Ich lese das jetzt nicht, weil ich das halt nicht mehr lese,
sondern ich lese davon, dass Leute davon lesen und das ganze ist jetzt irgendwie so eskaliert,
dass sogar die EU jetzt Twitter, Twix, Elon Musk persönlich,
ein ultimatum gestellt hat hier das doch mal binnen 24 stunden abzuschalten.
Thierry Breton, der für wirtschaft zuständig ist, wenn ich das jetzt richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Ja aber das, also seit wann kann denn irgendwie der EU Kommissar für Binnenmarkt
und Dienstleistung irgendwie 24 Stunden Ultimaten setzen?
Na, weiß ich nicht. Seitdem wir die passenden Richtlinien und Grundverordnungen verarbeitet haben.
Also er droht mit einer Strafe, das ist auch in Ordnung, aber ich glaube der
will einfach nur auch mal auf der Ebene mitspielen, oder?
Ja ich meine da müssen sie auch mitspielen, ich meine das ist ein Dienst,
der wird in Europa angeboten, da findet halt Moderation nicht mehr wirklich statt.
Und wir hatten nun das Thema vorhin gerade so mit den Wahlen und genauso ist
es natürlich bei solchen Ereignissen.
Die ganze Terrorpropaganda funktioniert halt auf der Basis,
dass dann erstmal möglichst viel Mythen und Verschwörungserzählungen losgelassen
werden in tausend verschiedenen Varianten bis halt keiner mehr weiß was wahr
ist und dann nimmt jeder irgendwas raus,
was gerade am besten zur Verstärkung des eigenen Weltbildes passt.
Und das Weltbild ist halt, was Juden und Israel im Besonderen betrifft,
halt sowieso in der ganzen Welt im Eimer.
Es ist halt einfach das Land, auf das immer wieder eingedroschen wird.
Und diese ganze Ja-Aber-Diskussion, die dann auch in Deutschland natürlich losgegangen
ist, ist halt einfach mal eine Katastrophe.
Man muss das einfach mal klar benennen, was hier passiert. Man hat es halt mit
dem Land zu tun, was einfach seit Jahrzehnten von seinen Nachbarn in seiner
Existenz infrage gestellt wird.
Und konkret die Hamas, die jetzt diese Angriffe geleitet hat,
ist halt einfach eine Organisation, deren Agenda die Zerstörung des Staates
Israel und der Tötung aller seiner Bürger in der Agenda hat.
Nicht mehr, nicht weniger.
Und das geht halt mal gar nicht. So und das, was halt jetzt gelaufen ist,
ist natürlich eine totale Katastrophe.
Von dem, was geschehen ist, ist es eine totale Katastrophe. Du wirst die Bilder
und Berichte auch gesehen haben, es ist halt einfach...
Furchtbar alles und für das land ist es natürlich klar dass es jetzt einfach
dagegen halten muss weil das geht halt nicht ich meine das würde hier auch nicht gehen.
Von irgendeiner grenze außerhalb von deutschland sachsen oder so.
Und einfach anfangen wahllos leute zu erschießen.
Also wir waren ja, ich dachte wir wären jetzt bei dem Brief von Thierry Breton.
Entschuldigung, das hat mich jetzt ein bisschen weggetragen,
aber das muss halt auch einfach mal klar gesagt werden,
weil ich halt auch, ich hab natürlich auch so in meinem Umfeld auch so,
ja aber, so, ne da gibt es kein aber.
Es geht halt nicht. Es ist halt einfach, das geht nicht. Und da muss man sich
genauso gegenstellen, wie gegen den Terror, den die Russen über die Ukraine
ausbreiten. Das ist einfach überhaupt kein anderes Thema.
Stimme ich zu?
Ich kann nur sagen, dass ich hoffe, dass die BewohnerInnen Israels das zu einem Anlass nehmen,
sich auch darüber Gedanken zu machen, was für Vollidioten sie da gewählt haben.
Also dieser, ich kann den Namen auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so genau aussprechen,
aber der Sicherheitsminister, der da auf den Tempelberg gerannt ist und so.
Also das sind alles, also das sind nicht Aktionen, das sind keine Provokationen
oder das sind alles keine Handlungen, die dieser Angriff rechtfertigen.
Aber es war auch allen klar, dass es ein Spiel mit exakt diesem Feuer ist so.
Und deswegen sollte man solche Vollidioten nicht wählen.
Das heißt nicht, dass die irgendwie die Schuld daran tragen oder dass die Angriffe
gerechtfertigt werden.
Aber wenn das Volk Israels in Sicherheit leben möchte,
was ja ein Wunsch ist, den alle Menschen hegen, Dann sollten sie natürlich auch
die Leute wählen, die einen belastbaren Weg haben und nicht für irgendwelchen
Scheiß dann auch noch ausgerechnet diese Arschgeigen provozieren.
Also ich meine, das ist vollkommen unbestreitbar, dass das Gesicht derzeit...
Ich muss es nochmal betonen, weil ich jetzt gleich wieder...
Also ich will mich ja eigentlich zu diesem Konflikt irgendwie...
Also zu diesem Konflikt äußere ich mich nicht, weil dann hast du eh nur Dumpfbacken
an der Backe von jeder Seite.
Aber, ja, ich würde, also das innenpolitische Geschehen Israels hat mir in den
letzten Monaten und Jahren dann doch auch sehr viel Sorgen gemacht, ne?
Das innenpolitische Geschehen fast jedes Staates macht einem Sorgen.
Also da ist jetzt Israel keine Sorgen und das ist halt auch in allen anderen
Ländern um Israel herum ist das innenpolitische Geschehen halt auch eine totale Katastrophe.
Das Rechtfertigkeit ist überhaupt
nichts. Das ist eine Israel interne Diskussion und vor 50 Jahren,
als das letzte Mal das passiert ist, dass Israel auf dem linken Fuß erwischt wurde,
ist danach die Regierung auch abgeräumt worden und da handelte es sich um niemand
anderes als Golda Meir, die jetzt sozusagen nicht unbedingt gerade besonders
unpopulär war, aber der Netanjahu, der ist sowieso schon unpopulär.
In den letzten Monaten sind da einfach sozusagen täglich Massendemonstrationen
durch das Land gegangen.
Ein Großteil der Reservisten hat, um dagegen zu protestieren,
was die da machen, den Reservistendienst verweigert.
Also das hat alles nachhaltig dazu beigetragen, dass sozusagen das Land aus
dieser Habachtstellung herausgeglitten ist. Und das wurde sozusagen jetzt auch
noch zusätzlich mit bestraft.
Konkret geht es dabei ja um was anderes, da geht es ja darum,
dass Netanyahu schon seit langem von Korruptionsprozessen verfolgt wird und
das Ganze alles schon an so einen Punkt kam, wo eigentlich klar ist,
dass er jetzt mal verurteilt wird.
Aber dann ist er halt wieder an die Macht gekommen, hat sich irgendwie mit diesen
Rechtsextremen zusammengetan, die sozusagen.
Die so allerlei zu Bedingungen gemacht haben und er musste aber auch zu allem
ja sagen zu diesem ganzen Quatsch den die vorgeschlagen haben und die natürlich
wie das immer bei diesen rechtsextremen Parteien ist einfach auch gar keine
Kompetenz für so Ministerämter in den eigenen Reihen haben.
Nur damit irgendwie so ein neues Gesetz veröffentlicht oder beschlossen werden
kann, was am Ende dazu führt, dass er nicht verurteilt werden kann.
Was letzten Endes natürlich die Rechtsordnung, die demokratische Rechtsordnung
Israels auch aus der Kraft setzen würde, weil es im Prinzip sagt,
die Politik darf quasi den Gerichten der Justiz vorschreiben,
was richtig ist und was nicht.
Mit anderen Worten sie können halt verhindern, dass der Ministerpräsident verurteilt
wird, weil das halt unangemessen wäre.
Und dagegen wurde halt demonstriert. Aber das sind innenpolitische Konflikte,
die mit dieser außenpolitischen Situation so erstmal nichts zu tun haben.
Und natürlich wird alles immer vermischt so und es geht bei diesem Thema Israel
geht es immer um alles und alles wird reingeworfen und diese ganzen Verschwörungstheorien,
was die Juden angeblich alles auf dieser Welt kontrollieren und so weiter,
vergiss es halt einfach.
Es ist halt einfach ein Land, was versucht in Ruhe gelassen zu werden.
Ich versuche nochmal die Kurve zu Elon Musk, weil er vor diesem Hintergrund,
der Brief, den jetzt Thierry Breton an Elon Musk schreibt,
endet mit dem Satz, ich bitte Sie eindringlich, diese Anfrage innerhalb der
nächsten 24 Stunden schnell, genau und vollständig zu beantworten.
Wir werden Ihre Antwort in unsere Bewertungsakte zur Einhaltung des Digital Service Act aufnehmen.
Und jetzt, letzter Satz ist der entscheidende, ich erinnere Sie daran,
dass nach der Einleitung einer möglichen Untersuchung und der Feststellung einer
Nicht-Einhaltung Sanktionen oder Strafen verhängt werden können.
Wenn wir eine Einleitung, eine Untersuchung einleiten und dann noch eine Nicht-Einhaltung
feststellen, dann könnten wir Strafen verhängen.
Das ist die Nachricht, die der wirklich sendet, statt zu sagen...
So das wäre nämlich der, das wäre natürlich mal was, mal sehen,
mal zeigen, zack bumm, mach doch mal.
Das macht er hier nämlich nicht, das heißt es ist eigentlich nur wieder so eine,
und deswegen finde ich diese Aktion jetzt auch so eher so halb spannend,
Interessant wird sein der Elon Musk wird dieses Ultimatum natürlich verstreichen
lassen, das macht man mit Ultimaten wenn sie einem gestellt werden.
Und dann wollen wir mal sehen was Thierry Breton macht.
Ja ich bin gespannt also ich meine das wäre jetzt mal genau der richtige Moment
den Rücken durchzudrücken und dann mal zu zeigen was denn diese tollen Gesetze
denn jetzt eigentlich können.
Genau. Könnte man jetzt mal sehen.
Dann würden wir mal sehen. Vielleicht bringt es ja auch mal was.
Bis jetzt können wir Strongly Worded Letters damit schreiben.
Genau.
Immerhin. Wir bleiben nämlich aber bei Thierry Breton.
Denn ich muss wahrscheinlich, der Name fiel bei uns in der Sendung nicht so
oft. Er ist bei uns gefallen, weil das war der mit dem Leitungsschutzrecht.
Ein wunderschöner Begriff von Tim. Also der Idee,
dass er sagt, hey, die Big Tech Companies, Google, Meta, Netflix,
Microsoft, Amazon und so, denen wollen wir jetzt Geld wegnehmen,
damit wir die Netze bauen können.
Ja, also wir nehmen diesen großen Unternehmen, die sind ja die größten im Internet,
also sind ja auch für den ganzen Traffic verantwortlich, den die Kunden machen.
Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt, müssen Deutsche Telekom, Orange,
Telefonica, Telekom Italica, Telekom Italia, die ja so viel Geld ausgeben,
um zeitgemäße Infrastruktur in diesem Land zu bauen.
Und wenn das alles am Ende da bei euch verballert wird, mit Googlen und Facen
und Netzen und Microsoft Teamsen und Amazon Shopping, dann sollt ihr das bitte bezahlen.
Und beziehungsweise, das machen wir ganz einfach, dafür, dass ihr unsere schöne
Infrastruktur nutzen könnt, müsst ihr dann eben bezahlen und damit finanzieren wir die.
Ja, wir wissen, Thierry Breton hat seine gesamte Karriere bei Telcos verbracht,
insofern ist es nicht überraschend, dass er da alte Bande pflegt und mit dieser
Idee des Leitungsschutzrechts sieht jetzt so aus,
dass das eher verschoben wird, weil das kriegen sie nicht mehr hin. Ja, also dass die...
EU-Telcos haben eigentlich erwartet, dass er dieses Fair-Share-Funding irgendwie
mit einer Internet-Tax, könnte man es natürlich auch nennen,
irgendwie noch in dieser Legislatur durchkriegt.
Aber das wird, da läuft es jetzt wohl darauf hinaus,
dass das auch eben, naja, der nächsten Kommission dann obliegt und nicht mehr
fertig gemacht werden kann. Das ist eine gute Nachricht.
Ja mal gucken, ob Breton in der nächsten Kommission auch noch angehört.
Das kann ich gerade gar nicht prognostizieren ehrlich gesagt.
Das weiß ich einfach nicht.
Das wird auch noch von vielen Fakten abhängen.
Ob der das überhaupt anstrebt. Die Prognose ist, dass er jetzt eine Strategie
aufsetzen wird, Um es der nächsten Kommission zu überliefern,
ob sie diese Legislation durchbringen möchte oder nicht.
Im November des nächsten Jahres ist die Kommission fünf Jahre gewesen, ist vorbei.
Jo, das ist eine gute Nachricht, sagt Thomas.
Ja also ich meine zumindest ist erst mal aufgeschoben so oder kann kann erst mal nicht stattfinden.
Genau. Dann haben wir noch ein kleines eine kleine Hintergrundrecherche ist
jetzt ungefähr ein Jahr her da gab es das sogenannte Griechenland Watergate
da ging es um die den Staatstrojaner Predator,
der in Griechenland gegen einen Journalisten, gegen den Oppositionsführer und
ein paar weitere eingesetzt wurde.
Gehackt von der eigenen Regierung. Das ist auch...
Mann ey. Stell dir mal vor.
Wir streiten aber alles an.
Stell dir mal vor, die würden sagen so... Olaf Scholz hat Friedrich Merz hacken
lassen und den abgehört.
Also stell dir mal vor, ich meine, würde ich sagen...
Endlich kümmert sich mal einer. Aber ich glaube das wäre schon so ein größerer Skandal.
Und wenn das dann noch so eine Schadsoftware ist, die an die ägyptische Regierung
und an Libyen verkauft, könnte man sagen einigermaßen skandalös.
Aber in Griechenland geht das.
Auch da hatte das natürlich ein entsprechendes politische Nachwirkung,
aber da geht es gar nicht drum, denn jetzt wurde mal hinterher recherchiert,
wo dieses Predator herkommt. Und das gehört nämlich einem Firmenverbund mit dem Namen Intellexa.
Und der wurde maßgeblich aus Deutschland finanziert.
Also spiegel tagesschau und so haben sich daran beteiligt das geld für die entwicklung
der software so unter anderem von einem venture kapitalisten mit sitz in der
kleinen stadt zossen gekommen sein.
Also du musst mal kurz zu sagen spiegel tagesschau haben sich nicht daran beteiligt
das zu finanzieren sondern haben sich an dieser recherche.
Ja natürlich an der Recherche, wir reden ja von der Recherche,
wir reden ja von der Recherche.
Und dann gibt es noch irgendwie einen Kulturinvestor namens Joram Roth,
der soll auch anderthalb Millionen Euro in einem der Unternehmen investiert
haben, ist ja auch ein Wachstumsmarkt, wenn man Zeitung aufschlägt.
Und jetzt ist es spannend, die haben sich dann mit Hilfe eines Hamburger Anwalts
die Exportkontrollenumgehung gemacht.
Also wir, diesen französischen Unternehmer, der wiederum ein anderes Unternehmen
in dieser Firmengruppe hatte, nach Libyen und Ägypten verkauft.
Und an die CITES. Die CITES ist seit 2019 Kunde bei Predator und wollen das
natürlich auch kaufen oder sind Kunde.
Und da wusste man schon,
dass der Kram nach Ägypten, Libyen verkauft wurde,
dass auch das natürlich spätestens mindestens seit einem Jahr weiß man,
dass es in Griechenland von der Regierung im Inland eingesetzt wurde gegen politische
Opposition und so weiter.
Es ist schon wirklich irre.
Das ist die Recherche. Auch hier wieder nichts Überraschendes.
Ich meine, als wir uns mit Finn Fischer auseinandergesetzt haben,
ich meine immerhin, wir erinnern uns, Finn Fischer ist dann am Ende pleite gegangen.
Und die Strafverfahren wegen der Umgehung von Exportkontrolle laufen immer noch.
Alles spannend, aber auch da sind es ja Deutsche gewesen.
Unter anderem die zentrale Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich.
Genau, sehr schön.
Also sozusagen deutsche Behörde finanziert Software, mit der die griechische
Regierung die Oppositionspolitiker ausforscht.
Ja. Haben wir noch einen schönen,
also das hab ich eigentlich, ich wollte das, ich wollte, ich hab das so gelesen
und gehört, wollte das eigentlich gar nicht unbedingt in der Sendung haben,
weil ich so dachte, na ok, ist eigentlich nichts besonderes.
Motel 1 wurde gehackt, da wurden irgendwie auch, weiß ich nicht,
wie viele Gigabytes rausgeschleppt und dann hat die Ransomware-Gang Black Cat bzw.
Alf V, nennen die sich auch, also...
Die haben mit der Veröffentlichung dieser Daten dann gedroht.
Und da sind Millionen von Menschen betroffen. 24 Millionen Dateien, sechs Terabyte.
Und ja, man kann also sagen, wenn die mit der Veröffentlichung von Daten drohen,
dann veröffentlichen die die auch. Ja, ich hatte schon mal mit denen zu tun beruflich.
Und das haben sie jetzt gemacht.
Und was die natürlich machen, die, also wenn solche Gangs mit der Veröffentlichung von Daten drohen,
dann wollen die ja eine Schutzgelderpressung haben,
beziehungsweise die wollen eine Erpressungszahlung haben,
was solche Gangs machen, ist üblicherweise, verschlüsseln dir zentrale Datenbestände
und wollen dir den Schlüssel dazu anbieten und um das,
sag ich mal, wenn du jetzt vielleicht sagst, ach nee komm, ich bin doch irgendwie
in der Lage, den Betrieb hier wieder herzustellen, ohne dass ich für den Schlüssel
zahle, was natürlich immer länger dauert. Die Frage ist, wie viel länger?
Dann nehmen sie halt einfach noch ordentlich Daten mit, exfiltrieren die und
drohen zusätzlich mit der Veröffentlichung.
Das heißt, das Angebot ist zweierlei.
A, wir löschen die Daten, die wir haben, und veröffentlichen sie nicht.
Und wir geben euch den Schlüssel zur Entschlüsselung der Daten,
die wir bei euch potenziell eben zerstört haben.
So, wenn die das machen, zu Beginn geben sie nicht bekannt, dass sie dich gehackt haben.
Zu Beginn der Verhandlungen kannst du noch davon ausgehen, dass die,
oder kannst du, weiß es die Öffentlichkeit zumindest nicht von dieser Gruppe.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie eine Betriebsunterbrechung hast,
die du nicht geheim halten kannst, dann landest du vielleicht irgendwo mal in der Presse,
weil du von einer Cyberattacke heimgesucht wurdest oder so,
aber wenn sich dann herausstellt, wenn ein bisschen Zeit vergeht und sich herausstellt,
dass du kein Interesse hast zu zahlen, dann suchen die gerne mal die Öffentlichkeit
oder haben halt so Blogs, auf denen sie erstens natürlich diese Dateien veröffentlichen
und zweitens, oder links zu den Dateien veröffentlichen.
Und zweitens auch so Ankündigungen machen, wer jetzt hier bald geleakt wird,
um den Druck zu erhöhen, damit es auch eben die öffentliche Debatte gibt,
zahlen die jetzt oder nicht.
Und Motel One hat nicht gezahlt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die Forderung war, aber es wird sicherlich ein paar
Millionen Euro gewesen sein. Man kann auch immer noch ein bisschen verhandeln.
Da haben wir auch ganz gute Erfahrungen mit.
Die Situation oder die Frage, die sich ja bei dieser Zahlung dann stellt,
und das ist keine einfache, ich will die nur mal so illustrieren,
ist, wenn Motel One gezahlt hätte, dann wären diese Dateien nicht veröffentlicht worden.
So. Natürlich hätte Motel One dafür
an Kriminelle bezahlt und deren Geschäftsmodell genährt und so weiter,
aber zumindest als jemand, der sich garantiert in diesen Daten befindet,
weil ich ein oder andere Mal schon in so einem Motel One war,
Habe ich vielleicht meine Überlegungen dazu, ob Motel 1 nicht vielleicht doch
hätte bezahlen sollen, um den Schaden von mir abzuwenden?
Also diese Möglichkeit, muss man zumindest mal sagen, hatte Motel 1 und haben
sich dagegen entschieden.
Schön ist, was sie dazu sagen, das sind 6 Terabyte.
Zum Beispiel so schöne Sätze wie Motel One hat nach Kenntnis des Hackerangriffs
unverzüglich sichergestellt, dass keine weiteren personenbezogenen Daten von
der Hackergruppe erlangt werden können.
Die haben alle man, was ist das denn?
Also sie haben zwar alle, aber mehr haben sie auch nicht gekriegt.
Ja, und sie haben mit IT-Sicherheitsexperten zusammengearbeitet.
Das ist natürlich Wahnsinn.
So, und dann?
Sie hätten natürlich auch mit der lokalen Bäckervereinigung zusammenarbeiten
können, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das so hilfreich gewesen wäre.
Interessant wäre natürlich gewesen, vorher mit Leuten zusammenzuarbeiten,
die sich damit auskennen.
Aber richtig geil ist Dieter Müller.
Das ist also der Mitgründer und Geschäftsführer oder so, der mit dem Laden ein
paar gute Millionen gemacht hat.
Ist auch betroffen.
Ja, natürlich ist der auch betroffen und vor allem weiß der auch genau,
was jetzt passieren muss.
Und er weiß auch, wer schuld ist. Und er antwortet dann auf Anfrage der Süddeutschen
Zeitung kein Wort des Bedauerns gegenüber seinen Kunden, stattdessen eine Forderung in Richtung Politik.
Die Politik muss die Cyberabwehr endlich erheblich aufrüsten,
denn leider hat der Staat noch
keinen Weg gefunden, seiner staatlichen Hoheitsaufgabe gerecht zu werden,
und seine Bürger und Unternehmen vor kriminellen digitalen Angriffen zu schützen.
Interessanter Spin.
Fand ich gut. Fand ich richtig gut. Dafür kriegt er die lobende Erwähnung. Ey das ist so.
Also um seine Server dicht zu kriegen setzt er aufs Verteidigungsministerium oder was?
Ja auf jeden Fall ist der Staat schuld.
Das ist ja super. Ja der Staat ist schuld, weil er hat ja nichts gegen Cyber gemacht.
Vor ein paar Tagen hat er in New York ein neues Konzept mit Rooftop Bars und
mehr Luxus gestartet, also er will jetzt irgendwie in New York irgendwie was machen.
Und im Focus Interview erzählt er dann, wie geil profitabel das ist.
Was er nicht erzählt ist, wie viele Staatshilfen er bekommen hat in der Zeit,
wo wegen Corona niemand in seine blöden Hotels gegangen ist.
Das hat er außen vor gelassen, das wurde mir dann auf Mastodon mal ergänzt,
wie viele Millionen Euro Subventionen dieser Laden bekommen hat.
Aber finde ich sehr schön.
Die zurückgezahlt wurden oder nicht zurückgezahlt?
Hier hat er, er schreibt mir, Mortal One hat in seiner Bilanzmeldung 2022 einen
Gewinn vor Steuern von 116 Millionen Euro ausgewiesen.
Damit hätte das Unternehmen genug Geld gehabt, um einen besseren Datenschutz zu gewährleisten.
Finde ich schon mal ganz guten Punkt. Datenschutz ist Aufgabe des Unternehmens natürlich.
Ja, aber Gewinne stehen ja nun auch erstmal den Aktionären zu.
Da muss man ja nicht gleich für sinnvolle Sachen ausgeben.
Denkt doch mal einer an die Aktionäre. Naja.
Nein, also da gibt es natürlich überhaupt keine Diskussion, das ist deren Verantwortung.
Also es ist, also genau, endlich mal Gewinne für staatliche Nibbler hat geantwortet.
2022 70 Millionen Gewinn, nachdem
sie in den Jahren zuvor gut 90 Millionen staatliche Hilfe erhalten hat.
Ja, sagen wir mal so, wenn ihr die 90 Millionen nicht kassiert hättet,
dann hätte der Staat vielleicht mehr Geld gehabt, um euch zu schützen, aber so.
Bestimmt. Vielleicht wäre es auch klug gewesen, einfach sich selber mal darum zu kümmern.
Zu muss natürlich noch sagen, also es ist nicht so einfach in,
also Hotelinfrastrukturen sind natürlich ein bisschen kompliziert.
Eine ganze Reihe an Angestellten, die sehr kurzfristig angelernt werden.
Das ist, da muss man schon die IT-Sicherheitsexpertinnen holen.
Bevor der Laden aufgemacht wird.
Danach ist nicht mehr viel zu holen.
Gespannt ob der Staat sich jetzt nicht vielleicht mal traut,
ich meine klar muss der Staat sich schämen, dass er es nicht geschafft hat Motel One zu schützen, ja.
Das ist das ist natürlich schon, also da hat er natürlich echt einen Punkt ja,
vielleicht schämt der Staat sich sogar so sehr, dass er jetzt gar nicht sich traut da.
Das System sollte sich was schämen.
Ja, glaub ich.
Ja, so geht es ja nun nicht.
Danke, Merkel, wollte ich noch dazu sagen.
Oh Mann, der Staat.
Geil, der Staat. Naja, okay.
So wir sind jetzt am Ende angekommen glaube ich ja, Ende der Sendung.
Noch ein kurzer Nachtrag, wir hatten ja letztes mal über Finanzierungsmodelle
und so weiter gesprochen,
da gab es noch ein paar Nachfragen, wie denn das so gehandhabt werden soll,
dann sage ich nochmal so eine Sache, die ich glaube ich letztes mal nicht so
erwähnt habe, also Uns sind natürlich kleine regelmäßige Spenden ein tausend
mal lieber als irgendwie so einmalige Zahlung.
Also falls ihr da irgendwie am abwägen seid, geht es um diese Planungssicherheit
und dass man irgendwie kontinuierlich irgendwas am Start hat.
Oder das ist natürlich die andere Möglichkeit kontinuierlich regelmäßig große
Spenden. Das nehmen wir auch. Oder?
Ich nehme alles. Ich bin da nicht so wählerisch. Der Tim der dreht jeden Tag
zwei mal um und sagt der kommt jetzt nicht oft genug oder so.
Unterstellung. Genau. Und wenn ihr die Wahl habt lieber SEPA als sowas wie Paypal.
Weil bei Paypal, du kennst das Spiel, klicken da nämlich alle immer beim Zahlen
auf den falschen Button.
Da kann man nicht sagen, ist für einen Händler oder ist für Freunde und Familie
und wir sind natürlich Freunde und Familie. Oder?
Wenn ich dir was schicke, wir beide sind Freunde, ja.
Wir sind Freund und Familie aller unserer Hörerinnen.
Ich glaube das würde ich so nicht sagen, aber ich habe auf jeden Fall ein großes Herz.
Aber die Hörerinnen sagen was. Ich habe ein großes Herz und viel Freundschaft zu geben.
Insofern, belangen wir euch auch nicht weiter, das war es von uns in dieser Woche.
Logbuch Netzpolitik 472.
Wir sagen jetzt einfach mal, wir wollen regelmäßig ohne Gebühren viel Geld.
So und wenn das die Technologie nicht liefert, dann muss sie eben erfunden werden Schluss, Schluss.
Tschüss. Bis nächste Woche.